Brooks lobs it up top for Java Rani's
picked up by Hampton good matchup here I
ran around a screen from Clark lob to
the rib for Jackson and he flushes home
with two hands perfect alley-oop to open
things on the play area head head to
turn over did came up on the clay stayed
with it and did was still able to make a
really good play out of that out of the
out of the loose ball
Webster straightaway three too strong
rebound Hampton misses his little run up
is there excitement about him Clark back
the other way alley-oop from John Moran
flushes it up turn I thought was ant was
it Andrew gays that kind of got the ball
rolling for everybody when he was
playing at Seton Hall with those great
teams and going to the Final Four with
the Pirates back then under PJ Carlesimo
English is not the primary language
spoken as Marant drives left wing hangs
and drops it off for Anderson couple of
pump fakes and he bangs it in off the
window Tennessee Volunteers shoulders
into Anderson has a turnaround
right-handed hook - Kyle blocks the
loose ball picked up by the Grizzlies
Moran on the attack left corner Gouda
rich his threes gun rang it up put three
on the board for Marco Gouda rich yeah I
think a little mature above his age
arrogant he's not into Russia plays
within himself just make good decisions
Jones right corner for Clark Clark into
the lane back out top for rant he
thought about the three kicks in the
corner for Crowder open three ring it up
put three on the board the extra math